PROFESSOR: Why don't
we get started.
Good afternoon--
to stretch the literal meaning
of the word considerably.
What a miserable
day out there.
I get to and from the boonies
via the commuter rail.
And this morning, we sat there
for an hour part way in
because a tree had fallen across
the railroad track.
I don't know who went out to do
it, but somebody had to get
a saw and saw the tree up and
take it off the tracks before
we could proceed into Boston.
Even with that, I was
sort of reluctant
to get off the train.
I saw how it was pouring
outside.
So I am highly flattered that
you decided to trudge through
the puddles and show
up this afternoon.
All right, this is a momentous
occasion because we are
exactly at this point, halfway
through the term.
And this is when we are about
to change gears from our
discussion of symmetry theory
and switch over to physical
properties of crystals and the
way in which symmetry impacts
on those properties.
What I wanted to do primarily
today, though, is to say a
little bit in a very fast and
very simple way about the
nature of crystal structures
because that is one of the
primary uses of symmetry
theory.
It's to describe the periodic
arrangements and symmetrical
arrangements of atoms
in crystals.
So it's the language that's
necessary to describe such
arrangements, particularly when
they're beyond the red
balls at the corner of the cube
and black balls in the
middle of the faces level
of structure.
Let me first, for your amusement
and edification,
pass out another problem set.
This has only two
problems on it.
You are not really equipped to
do it yet because we haven't
talked about space groups.
So don't worry about
doing that now.
But I wanted to get it in
your hand so that you
could look it over.
It's a good problem set on which
to end this part of the
discussion--
but there's another
one that I'll be
passing out next week--
because this is an example of
how you can use the notions of
symmetry that we have
established to say some fairly
profound and non-obvious things
about the nature of
atomic arrangements.
So that's the purpose
of this problem set.
It is to give you an opportunity
to see the
surprising things that can fall
out of our material that
we now have at our disposal.
Let me begin by telling you
where we left off last time.
We had completed deriving the
so-called Bravais lattices,
the three-dimensional
space lattices.
The process by which we did
this was to take our
two-dimensional space groups,
the plane groups, and say
that, if we add a third
translation, we will have
generated a space lattice.
But these different nets in
the base of the cell are
special and determined by the
fact that there are symmetry
in these nets.
So if we take, for example, a
net that is exactly square--
it's square because there's
a fourfold axis there.
And that fourfold axis, in a
space lattice, pokes not only
into the base of the cell but
extends up through space.
So you must pick a third
translation such that the
symmetry elements line up.
We would take each of the
crystallographic plane groups
and pick a third translation.
You end up with almost all of
the lattices that you're going
to get except for the ones that
involve cubic symmetries
that are inherently
three-dimensional.
And the reason for that is
that the more complex
three-dimensional point groups
are, for the most part,
obtained by adding inversion to
the simple symmetries that
exist in two dimensions.
But inversion doesn't require
anything of a lattice.
So you can immediately say that
2M and 2/M are compatible
with the same sort of space
lattice because the symmetry
2/M is nothing more than what
you get when you add inversion
to either a twofold axis
or a mirror plane.
And, finally, another way of
classifying crystals, and a
broader way of classifying
them, is according to the
coordinate systems that
are necessary to
describe the lattices.
And these are called the
crystal systems.
And, as a mnemonic device for
keeping straight what the
crystal systems are as opposed
to the crystal classes, which
is another word that we haven't
used but it's another
word for the point groups, the
crystal systems goes with
coordinate systems.
And it's simply a word to
describe the shape of the
lattices, family of lattices,
that we've described.
And we distributed a handout
last time that gave the names
of these systems and the
relations that exist between
the edges of the unit cell,
which we use as the basis for
our coordinate system
and also the labels
that we put on them.
I have another sheet, which
I'll pass around, which is
nothing new.
It just assembles--
I'll give you two sheets,
which I'll pass around.
The first is an assembly of
the crystallographic point
groups in a somewhat neater and
tidier way than we had on
the sheet that we passed
around last time.
So this is a picture of all
32 of the point groups.
Again, beware of the fact that
mirror planes and guides to
the eye that split things up
into 90 degree segments or 60
degree segments come
out deceptively
similar on these sheets.
But there with the
representative pattern are the
arrangements of symmetry
elements, a representative
pattern of motifs, and the
international and [INAUDIBLE]
symbol for all 32 of the
three-dimensional point groups.
And then the next sheet I'll
pass around takes the point
groups and groups them together
with the lattices
that can accommodate them and
the crystal system that
describes the arrangement
of axes in the lattice.
So this is, in a nutshell,
everything that we've covered
up to this point.
And, at this point, I have
to say that there is some
disagreement on how many
crystal systems exist.
And even though people who
work with symmetry and
mathematics are usually
rational, almost to a fault
logical individuals, there are
several junctures as you build
up a body of knowledge where
you could go either way or
adopt either convention.
You sort of got to pay your
money and take your choice.
And this occurs in our
arrangement of point groups
and lattices among the
crystal systems.
This occurs in the hexagonal
crystal system.
Symmetry 3 and the other point
groups that can be derived
from it can be placed either in
a hexagonal lattice, that
is to say, a third translation
C that is exactly at right
angles to a pair of
translations, A1 and A2, which
are 120 degrees apart.
Or a three-fold symmetry can go
into this funny double-body
centered hexagonal lattice,
which could be defined, if we
were masochistic and enjoyed
working in an oblique
coordinate system, could be
defined instead in terms of a
rhombohedral lattice, which
had the special
characteristics that three
translations are identical by
symmetry, called therefore A1,
A2, and A3; and the angles
between the more equal alpha 1,
alpha 2, alpha 3; and they
could be anything we wished.
So that is a unique sort of
crystal system and unique sort
of coordinate system.
There are those who would say
that if this is the case, we
really have seven crystal
systems--
triclinic; monoclinic;
orthorhombic; tetragonal;
hexagonal; and then this one
that is compatible only with a
three-fold axis and that is
called the trigonal system or,
by some folks, the rhombohedral
system; and then,
finally, the cubic.
Well isn't that a rational
and logical thing to do?
Yeah, question at this point?
AUDIENCE: Do you have any extra
copies of the sheet
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, yes.
There should be more than
enough floating around.
This one here?
[? AUDIENCE: The ?]
[? chart ?]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, [? not the ?]
[? chart ?].
PROFESSOR: OK.
I'll give you--
I think there are
more back there.
But why don't you take
one for now?
Yeah, so it's a perfectly
reasonable thing to do is to
set up the trigonal system as
a separate coordinate system
to describe the rhombohedral
lattice.
The problem that creates,
however, is that if you do
this, there is no longer any
one to one correspondence
between the point groups and
the crystal systems.
A crystal with symmetry 3, for
example, can fit into it
either in a hexagonal lattice
or a trigonal lattice.
US So sometimes a crystal with
point group 3 would have to be
called a hexagonal crystal,
sometimes a trigonal system.
But which is it?
Well it can be either.
So admitting the trigonal system
as a separate crystal
system breaks down the one to
one correspondence between
point groups and crystal
systems.
The very pragmatic reason for
not admitting the trigonal
system as a separate
crystal system
is that, although you can in
this funny triple hexagonal
cell define a primitive trigonal
cell that has a
special geometry, nobody in
their right mind, as I
indicated earlier, would
want to work in such
a coordinate system.
Better to take the triple
cell, pay the price of
three-fold redundancy, and yet
have two interaxial angles
that are 90 degrees and one
that's specialized at 120.
That's a much more convenient
reference system for our
description of crystal
properties.
One final thing I'll comment
on but won't say anything
about very much--
I always do that.
I say I won't say anything about
it but, and then launch
into a 10 minute digression.
Off in the right hand corner is
something called the Laue
group of which there are 11.
The Laue groups are those of the
point groups that contain
the operation of inversion.
And the reason they're called
the Laue groups is that one of
the primary ways, other than
looking at crystal morphology
to determine the symmetries of
a crystal, is to look at the
way it diffracts x-rays.
So if we had, for example a
tetragonal crystal and there
were lattice planes in here that
were related by 90 degree
rotations, then if we brought
in an x-ray beam at such an
angle to satisfy Bragg's law and
saw some sort of intensity
that came off, if we rotated the
x-ray beam 90 degrees, we
ought to see diffraction at
the same angle and with
exactly the same intensity.
So either by moving the x-ray
beam, or simpler thing would
be to leave the x-ray beam
fixed, since it's attached to
an x-ray generator that weighs
a ton or more, instead move
the crystal relative
to the x-ray beam.
Now what would you do in this
way of thinking to determine
whether a crystal had the
operation of inversion in it?
If this is the set of planes
with indices HKL, you, again,
would bring in an x-ray beam
at an angle theta, in out.
Look at the intensity from
the set of points HKL.
And then look at diffraction,
both in terms of the Bragg
angle theta and in terms
of the intensity.
Look at that diffraction from
the planes that were related
to HKL by symmetry.
Well what plane is related
to HKL by symmetry?
It's these planes down here
which have indices minus H,
minus K, minus L.
So if we did the corresponding
experiment to what I did to
the left, we'd bring in an
x-ray beam like this.
It would be diffracted
at some angle theta.
And we'd look at the intensity
for the set of planes minus H,
minus K, minus L.
Is that going to be
any different?
No.
Right-minded person would
say, why should this
intensity be different?
All we're doing is bouncing
the x-ray beam off the
opposite side of one in the same
set of lattice planes.
So why should the intensity
be any different?
In this case, clearly if the
set of lattice points is
rotated by some finite angle,
we are not going to see
equivalent diffraction
from planes that
are 90 degrees apart.
So the upshot is that the
diffraction symmetry of a
crystal, the way in which planes
with indices that are
related by symmetry diffract
in terms of position of the
beam and intensity, the
diffraction symmetry of a
crystal always looks as though
that crystal possessed an
inversion center.
So, therefore, to--
and I qualify this by saying,
to a good approximation--
the only point groups that
you could determine and
distinguish from one another by
x-ray diffraction are the
point groups that contain
an inversion center.
Almost, but not quite.
If we look a little more closely
at what is doing the
scattering, it is not
the Bragg planes.
These are imaginary, shimmering,
absolutely planar
things that are constructs that
we use to interpret the
process called diffraction.
Inside the crystal what is
actually doing the diffraction
is a collection of atoms, each
of which are scattering the
x-radiation.
And that physically is what
causes the diffraction.
And the resultant intensity is
the addition of all the little
wavelets scattered by these
separate atoms.
So in terms of the atomistics
of what is involved, to look
at diffraction from the set of
planes HKL and contrast that
with the diffraction for the set
of planes minus H, minus
K, minus L, we're coming in
from opposite directions.
And here the beam would hit--
let's call the atoms, if I did
not do so already, let's call
them A and B. A for
a and b for big.
Diffraction from the set of
points HKL would pass through
the sheets of A atoms first
and then impinge on the B
atoms, whereas in the opposite
direction, the x-ray beams
would impinge upon the
B atoms first and
then hit the A atoms.
Does that make a difference?
Aha.
Believe it or not, it does.
And I can't explain why without
going into a very
detailed discussion
of diffraction.
But if you compare the
intensities that are scattered
by these two sets of planes,
which are related by inversion
and therefore just opposite
sides of one another, it does
make a difference which
atom the x-ray
beam encounters first.
And the difference in intensity
is on the order of
3% to 5%, although by picking a
radiation appropriately for
the particular chemical species
in the crystal, you
could increase this perhaps
to 10% or 12%.
But that is something that you
could not do until synchrotron
radiation came along, which
could actually tune the
wavelength to a particular value
that you wish to use and
not use something that was
spewed out by an x-ray tube
that had a target such as
molybdenum or copper or
chromium, perhaps.
OK, so you can with this
careful measurement of
intensity distinguished between
the opposite sides of
the given set of Bragg planes,
unless, of course, the crystal
did have inversion in it.
And then there would be
no difference at all.
It requires a very careful
experiment, though, because
there are many things
that could make
the intensities different.
For example, absorption
by the crystal.
If the crystal has an
irregular shape, the
absorption, which can easily
be factors 10, 20, or even
more, the absorption would be
different for x-ray beams
coming in those two
orientations.
So in any case, as I say, I
won't say anything about it.
But 10 minutes later,
that's the
meaning of the Laue groups.
These are the point groups that
have inversion in them.
That effect that I just
described, by the way, is
called anomalous scattering
or anomalous dispersion.
There's really nothing anomalous
about at all.
It has to do with the way
electromagnetic radiation
interacts with the clouds of
electrons that are distributed
about the nucleus
of each atom.
Where we will go from here to
finish up symmetry theory will
be to now take the 32
crystallographic point groups
and to drop those point groups
into each of the distinct 14
Bravais lattices.
And then we'll need combination
theorems to deduce
where the additional symmetry
elements arrive.
And when we go through that
process, if we were to do this
exhaustively, we would find that
there are 230 distinct
three-dimensional symmetries
that involve point group
symmetry operations
and lattice type.
I saw several faces blanch.
Don't worry.
We're not going to do that.
What we will do next time is
do a small handful and then
conclude by showing you how this
information is tabulated
in the international tables.
And the quick, immediate answer
to that question is
that the problem set that I
passed around has two pages
for two different point groups
that show the way that this
information is tabulated in
the international tables.
So that's where we'll end up.
And we'll come pretty close to
completing that when we meet
on Thursday.
I heard no sighs of relief.
I heard no cheers.
So you are presumably
still engaged in
this material somewhat.
I have two things I
would like to do.
We talked about crystal systems
and point groups.
And let me now ask, do you think
there is a crystal known
for every one of the
point groups?
Think so?
I saw some skeptical
shakes of the head.
The answer is yes, but
just barely for some
of the point groups.
One of the very rare point
groups, in terms of structures
that populate it, is our high
symmetries but which lack
inversion or mirror planes.
One very, very rare point
group is 432--
just axes arranged in a cubic
arrangement with no mirror
planes or inversion centers.
And my rationalization of that
is that if an arrangement of
atoms has to conform to all of
these rotational symmetries,
it's pretty hard for it to do it
and have that assemblage of
atoms assume the lowest possible
energy state if it
doesn't pick up in the process
inversion or mirror planes as
additional symmetry element.
Sort of satisfying for me.
But that's not a rigorous
argument.
OK, let me now take a poll.
Do you think, using the broader
cut of the crystal
systems, do you think there's
a crystal known for every
crystal system?
Are there triclinic, monoclinic,
orthorhombic,
tetragonal, trigonal,
hexagonal,
cubic crystals known?
Yeah.
That's a pretty realistic
expectation.
And that is indeed the case.
But now let me cut this
a little finer.
Which do you think is the most
popular crystal systems for
real materials and which do
you think is the rarest?
OK.
Who thinks triclinic crystals
are the most common?
OK, there are pessimists.
What is the definition
of a pessimist?
The pessimist is somebody you
should borrow money from
because they'll never expect
to be paid back.
Who would say cubic crystals?
There are naive [? optimists. ?]
Now I will reveal all.
The answer is, it depends.
Depends upon whether you're
talking about, interestingly,
inorganic materials or whether
you're talking
about organic materials.
If you look at inorganic
materials, the most popular
crystal systems are--
and the results are, first
of all, cubic.
Is this not a benign world
in which we live.
Most inorganic materials--
if you're a material scientist
who works with metals and with
ceramics, you're going to work
with cubic materials, thank
God, most of the time.
The second most popular--
by a considerable margin but
there are still a lot of
them-- is orthorhombic.
And the third most popular,
shortly behind orthorhombic
and almost in a tie, monoclinic
and tetragonal.
We'll launch into a quick
overview of crystal symmetry.
And we'll see why inorganic
materials have high symmetry.
It's true, in particular, when
the material is held together
by ionic bonding.
If the bonding is ionic, it's
non-directional and atoms of
opposite charge will therefore
try to get as close as
possible to the atoms
of opposite charge.
And because atoms of like charge
repel one another, the
surrounding atoms will
try to be as widely
separated as possible.
And this grouping of atoms,
positive around negative,
tends to have a lot
of symmetry.
And, therefore, the way in which
these groups are linked
together has a lot
of symmetry.
OK, I said organic materials.
And I'll pass around some
actual numbers that were
assembled a long time ago but
are still, in terms of
proportion, still valid.
The organic compounds are broken
down into whether these
are compounds based on rings or
extended, lopsided molecules.
And the numbers are very
different depending on that.
But, for organic molecules
[? material, ?]
monoclinic is the most common,
then orthorhombic.
And shortly after orthorhombic
comes way, way behind is
tetragonal and triclinic,
which are almost tied.
And I think I can rationalize
this observation, as well.
Organic materials contain
discrete molecules.
And if we've got something-- and
I'm going to, since I know
I'm among friends, display
my abysmal
ignorance of organic chemistry.
I am unapologetically and
unabashedly inorganic and even
non-metallic in my research
interests.
So let's suppose we have
something that's composed of
various strange rings with
little side groups sticking
off like this, another one off
like this, and then maybe
another ring up like this.
That, to me, looks like a
reasonable molecule in terms
of my ignorance of organic
chemistry.
So if there are these finite
groups and you're going to put
them together in a crystal,
what are you
going to try to do?
They're going to be held
together by very weak van der
Waals forces, which are
non-directional.
So think of the outline of this
molecule as being some
ugly thing like a ham hock.
And then your problem, if the
forces between these molecules
are non-directional, how do
you close pack ham hocks?
The way you would do it would
be to put down a row of them
in a close-packed sequence.
So we'll put down things
that look like this.
And then, maybe to make them fit
together, dovetail another
one in here.
And maybe something like that.
And then for the next row down,
and you would maybe put
the nose of one in here.
And then put the other one in
here, the nose of one here,
and something like that--
being very schematic.
The lattice that describes this
packing is not going to
be orthogonal.
It's not going to be square
with high symmetry or even
have two orthogonal
translations.
It's going to be something that
has this as translations.
There's going to be an A
and a B that is not at
right angles to it.
And the B translation will have
different links, simply
because the thing that you're
putting together in close
packing has a very
irregular shape.
So I think that is the reason
why molecules, discrete
molecules that try to achieve
something that is as close
packed as possible, will have
translations in them that are
of unequal length and making
arbitrary angles with respect
to one another.
So having kept you guessing for
so long, let me pass out
another sheet.
This was a compilation that
was done a long time ago.
And there were only 9,000
crystals for which complete
crystallographic data
had been obtained.
This was way back in 1967.
As I say, there's much
more data now,
easily in order of magnitude.
But I don't think
the proportions
will change very much.
They'll stay about the same.
Let me pass out these sheets.
So make sure you memorize them
because the first question on
the next quiz is, how many
out of 8,759 crystals
are actually triclinic?
I would never do that.
All right, any comments
or questions?
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Why would organic
molecules of such odd shapes
even be crystalline
to begin with?
Why wouldn't they just
be amorphous?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Clearly the interatomic
forces are very
directional and very strong.
And that's going to hold the
molecule into a fixed
configuration.
AUDIENCE: Didn't you say there
were van der Waals forces?
PROFESSOR: But they're these--
even for something that is not
ionic or metallic, there still
are weak attractive forces
between these molecules.
Why?
Well, the charges are not
uniformly distributed over
these molecules.
So there are going to be some
van der Waals forces that tend
to hold them together.
And a van der Waals force is
essentially non-directional.
So if you have this weak force,
you're going to be able
to squish the crystal
into something
amorphous very easily.
And organic materials are
usually very subject to
plastic deformation.
But if you assemble the
molecules carefully from
solution, or by vaporization,
condensation, they're going to
want the order if they are
solidified with enough
mobility to rearrange themselves
in the lowest
energy configuration.
I think what you're saying is
these are not going to be very
strongly bonded crystals.
They're going to melt
at low temperatures.
But, nevertheless, prepare them
properly, and the lowest
energy state will be ordered.
AUDIENCE: I'm sure
[? they're ordered. ?]
But would it be such that you
have [? translational ?]
symmetry?
Who's to say it's going to have
a definite pattern that
will repeat itself?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, if there
are attractive forces--
let me again use a hand-waving
argument.
If you've got a bunch of
particles and they aggregate
here in the lowest energy
configuration, that is going
to be the lowest energy
configuration.
And a similar group of
atoms will want to do
the same thing here.
And if there are interactions
between these groups, they're
going to arrange themselves
in an order configuration.
That is simply saying--
this is a very weak qualitative
argument-- says if
you have a configuration which
is the lowest energy
arrangement here, any other
place in the system where
those atoms get together and
congeal are going to assume
that same configuration.
OK?
Other comments or questions?
This is all very qualitative but
actually concerns matters
that we are describing a
language to describe.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Yes, there are.
If you look at this table that
came around, if you look at
cubic organic materials
out of--
there--
what is the number?
117 out of what looks to
be several thousand.
Yes, there are cubic
organic crystals,
but very few in number.
Hexagonal--
56 out of a rather
large number.
All right, when we took a poll
a week and a half or so ago
and said, how many of you had
seen any material and crystal
chemistry in solid state
chemistry in a previous class
on structure and bonding or
crystal chemistry, and only a
few people tentatively twitched
a hand slightly.
So what I'd like to do for the
rest of this session, since
this is what symmetry theory is
developed to describe, I'd
like to say something about
structures and why they form
the way they do to give some
qualitative insight.
This is a fat pack of notes.
And I'll go over it quickly with
you and lead you by the
hand through it.
But this is not material
for which I'll hold you
responsible.
In fact, I'll turn my back and
those who want to get home
early because of the rain
can tiptoe out.
And I won't even notice who you
are unless everybody goes.
And then I'll feel very hurt
because I wrote these out.
And it took a lot of trouble.
All right.
I have to apologize and say that
most of what is described
in these notes applies to ionic
bonding and, to a lesser
extent but still in large
measure, to metallic
structures.
And what is the reason
for that?
It's because the metallic bond,
to a fair approximation,
an ionic bond rigorously, if you
believe Coulomb's law, is
a non-directional
sort of bonding.
So the structures that are
assumed, the structures that
are the lowest energy
configuration turn out to be
determined by interatomic
distances and ionic or
metallic sizes.
The Coulombic interaction that
holds ionic compounds together
is a central force.
And one of the features of
electromagnetism is that, if
you have some distribution of
charge about center and
another distribution of charge
of a different sort about a
another center, the cohesive
force between, let's say, a
positive ion and a negative ion
is, along a line, joining
their centers.
And, secondly, you can take,
once you're outside the
distribution of charge, you
can clump all the charge
together at the center
of the distribution.
So that's what makes the
ionic bond so simple.
And that's why everybody who
talks about bonding and
structure discusses ionic
bonding because organic
chemistry is just too complex
in comparison.
So let's look at
a given cation.
And cations generally tend to be
smaller than anions because
you've removed electrons from
the outer configuration.
We'll look at some effective
sizes of ions in just a bit.
But you've stripped electrons
off to make a positively
charged ion.
You've added electrons on to
make a negatively charged ion.
So when you add electrons, the
ion functions has [? always ?]
had a larger radius.
So let's bring up a B minus
ion as a neighbor.
And for those two species,
there will be, if we put
energy as a function of
separation D, there's going to
be a Coulombic attractive
force that goes as 1/D.
But when the electron
configurations get in to close
proximity, at small separations,
the electrons
will start to push one another,
beginning with the
outer electrons first, into
higher energy states.
And the energy of interaction,
due to the interaction of
orbitals, will increase the
energy of the system.
And the result then is that
the net potential, as a
function of distance for
an isolated ion pair--
I was looking for some colored
chalk and it's gone-- is
something that rises steeply
at low separations and then
levels out more gradually
at larger separations.
So this then would be an
equilibrium separation, D0,
for that ionic pair.
If we got energy out, and for
that isolated ionic pair it'll
be just exactly this
much energy, E0.
If it weren't for
a pair of ions--
let's take another A and bring
it into the system.
And there's a lot of room to
put still another A around.
And we can add that
to the system.
And every time we bring up an
additional neighbor, we get
approximately this much energy
out of the system.
But not quite because there
will also be repulsive
interactions between the
ions of like charge.
OK?
But to a good approximation
to within about 10% to be
quantitatively, every time we
bring up another neighbor, we
get out the same amount
of energy again by
forming this group.
And all that works splendidly
until--
let me now look at the
arrangement of anions about
the little cation because
they will have to
have a shell as well.
So if we have a small cation
and we bring up a big fat
anion, there will be, first
of all, two consequences.
These ions of like charge will
interact repulsively.
So the lowest energy situation
is going to be one in which
these neighboring ions arrange
themselves so that the
repulsive energy is minimized.
And we're going to get the
maximum separation between all
of these anions and get the
minimum energy when they
arrange themselves on the
corners of a regular
polyhedron.
And that's where symmetry
starts to come in to the
importance of ionic
structures.
That, for this particular
configuration of anions, the B
ions might be on the corners.
And I am not drawing them in
contact now just so it'll be
easier to draw.
The B ions will be equidistant
and tend to arrange themselves
on the corner of the
regular polyhedron.
If we got energy up by bringing
up extra neighbors,
we will reach a point where the
B ions will essentially be
in contact.
And the A ion is rattling
around in a hole.
It can touch perhaps
two neighbors.
And we will get the full
amount of energy on.
But for the other two neighbors,
we're going to be
out here on this curve.
And we won't get nearly
as much energy out.
But at the same time, we're
paying the price energetically
of all of these repulsive
interactions between the
surrounding neighbors
of like charge.
So the second consideration is
that, as we said, first of
all, this group of atoms, which
is referred to as a
coordination polyhedron,
it first
of all will be symmetric.
And then the number of
neighbors, the number of ions
of one charge that are
coordinating the others--
and that's something called
the coordination number,
introduce some jargon--
has an upper limit that is going
to be determined by the
size of the ions.
So these are the two
basic tenets of
ionic crystal chemistry.
So having established those
points, we can do some
geometry and assume that the
ions are hard spheres or at
least elastic spheres with some
stiffness because it's
going to take energy to perturb
the orbitals of the
electrons and, just in terms of
simple geometry, calculate
the range of radius ratios RA/RB
where A is the central
ion in the polyhedron and B is
the surrounding ion, and do
this for different coordination
numbers, picking
polyhedra in which the
surrounding ions of like
charge are as widely separated
as possible.
So starting at the beginning,
coordination number one would
be a pair of ions.
Obviously no constraints
whatsoever on
the relative sizes.
RA/RB can be anywhere it likes
between zero and infinity.
For coordination number two,
again the surrounding ions
want to be as widely separated
as possible.
So it'll be a linear chain.
But, again, the central ion
can become as small or as
large as it like.
So the range of radii is between
zero and infinity.
For coordination number three,
the polyhedron will be an
equilateral triangle.
And if you calculate the
geometry, when the B ions are
exactly in contact, you have a
little 30, 60, 90 triangle in
which one edge of the triangle
is RB and the
other is RA plus RB.
And you can manipulate that into
the form where you can
show that there will be a lower
limit RA/RB, which is 2
over the square root
of 3 minus 1.
And that turns out to be
a magic number, 0.155.
Going to coordination number
four, you'd say, aha.
That's going to be
square group.
No, a square group would not
keep the surrounding ions of
like charge as widely separated
as possible.
And the geometry which would
keep them as widely separated
as possible but yet in contact
with the central sphere would
be a tetrahedron.
The Bs would be arranged
on alternating
vertices of a cube.
The magic number there turns
out to be 0.225.
Coordination five--
very, very rare.
Five is a crystallographic
abomination because five-fold
symmetry does not conform
to a lattice.
But there would be,
in principle,
one five-fold group.
And that would be a trigonal
prism where you have three Bs
arranged on an equilateral
triangle about the central A.
And then you have one A up here,
another B up here, and
another B down here.
So this, then, is a bipyramid,
a triangular bipyramid.
And you can derive a range of
radius ratios for this.
And this is a dandy problem
to give on a problem set.
But you find that the range of
radius ratios RA/RB is the
same as for six-fold
coordination, which is the
next one considered
on the handout.
So we six coordination with
the corners on a regular
arrangement would be
an octahedron.
And the permitted range there
is 0.732 to infinity.
Five coordination, the trigonal
prism, leads to
exactly the same
range of radii.
And the reason is, if you look
at the geometries, this
triangle here is the same
for both an octahedral
coordination and a trigonal
pyramidal coordination.
Notice as we chug on that the
lower limit to the radius
ratio is gradually increasing.
And if we go to coordination
number eight, cubic
coordination, it goes
up to 1 to infinity.
And for coordination number
12, RA/RB has to
be exactly 1 period.
And that would be what
you achieved in the
close-packed number.
OK, turning the page.
There is also going to be a
range of radius ratios that's
determined by the number of As
that can be packed around a
central B. And doing exactly the
same calculation, if, for
example, four-fold coordination
permitted in
terms of RA/RB, the range
is 0.225 to infinity.
If we want to know the limits
for packing of A around B with
tetrahedral coordination, this
would give us numbers RA/RB
that were exactly the same range
of numbers because we've
just changed the labels.
If we want to put everything on
the same basis, in terms of
one particular radius ratio,
if we do anion to cation
radius ratio, the range would
be 0.225 to infinity.
If we take the reciprocals of
these numbers for four-fold
coordination of B, this
would be 1 over
0.225 to 1 over infinity.
So this will give us--
this is zero.
This is infinity.
So there'll be a range of radius
ratios, 0.225 less than
RA/RB, less than 1 over 0.225,
which turns out to be 4.44.
So this would be the range of
permitted radius ratios for
CNA equals 4 and CNB equals
the same thing, 4.
So there's going to be an upper
limit that's imposed by
the packing of As around B and
a lower limit that's imposed
by the packing of Bs around A.
But what are going to
be the coordination
numbers of A and B?
Let me finish this up.
And then we can take
our break.
I'm going to now restrict things
rather drastically.
I'm going to consider binary
compounds in which all cations
have the same coordination and
all anions with the same
coordination.
And the implication there is
there's only one type of
coordination number for both.
And that's not always
true in compounds.
Sometimes you find a given
species that has two different
coordination numbers in a
more complex compound.
If that's the case, if this is
the A ion and this is the B
ion, let me consider
the chemical
composition of a bond.
And that's going to translate
into the same
thing as the compound.
So let's suppose there's a
number of Bs around the As,
which is, by definition, the
coordination number of A, and
a number of As around a B and
that is, by definition, the
coordination number of B. So let
me look at a wedge that's
associated with this bond.
And this is an amount of an A
atom, which is 1 over the
coordination number of A.
And if I do the same thing for
the B ion the part of the B
ion associated with one bond
is going to be 1 over the
coordination number of B. So
we can say then that the
composition of a bond is going
to be A subscript 1 over the
coordination number of A, B, 1
over the coordination number
of B.
The chemists abhor fractional
subscripts on a chemical
composition.
So let's multiply this by
the product of the two
coordination numbers.
And what we'll find is that the
formula of the compound
with integer subscripts is going
to be A, C, and B; B
coordination number of A. And
that is a subject to a very
drastic set of assumptions that
each species A and B has
just one coordination number.
OK, so doing this in terms of
composition, just turning this
result around.
And then we'll quit and
take a stretch.
This says that if we look at a
particular composition, AnBm,
something like TiO2 or Al2O3,
then the coordination number
of A in proportion to the
coordination number of B is
going to be equal to the
ratio of M to N.
And the more ions of one charge
that we can pack around
the other, the lower
the energy will be.
And, therefore, the coordination
numbers will be
the maximum permitted values of
CNA and CNB, subject to the
constraints of radius ratio.
In other words, to conclude very
quickly with one specific
example, if we look at a
compound like Al2O3, an
important ceramic and a
gemstone, this says that the
coordination number of Al to the
coordination number of the
oxygen has to be equal
to three to two.
So possible structures might be
aluminum with coordination
number three, oxygen
with coordination
number equal to two.
Or aluminum could have
six coordination.
The oxygen could have
four coordination.
Or the aluminum could have
12 coordination.
And the oxygen could have
eight coordination.
Those three possibilities.
Next we have to use the ionic
sizes to see what constraints
there are that are going to
limit the maximum coordination
numbers because the greater the
number of neighbors, the
lower the energy.
And, in the case of aluminum
oxide, it turns out that it's
six to four.
And this is determined
by the radius ratio.
And you know what?
If we used the ionic radii for
Al3 plus and O2 minus, we were
right one the nose.
That is the nature of the
structure of aluminum oxide--
aluminum with octahedral
coordination by oxygen and
oxygen with a tetrahedral
coordination of aluminum.
And that is the actual
structure.
The three-dimensional linkage
would have to be such that
ions of like charge have the
maximum possible separation.
And to keep you beyond your
patience for just a little
bit, what is that going to be?
We can use very simple
considerations there.
If we have coordination
polyhedra and we want to join
them together, the worst
possible situation is to have
them share edges because the
central ions then had minimum
separation.
The better situation would be to
have to the polyhedra share
corners and have the ions in the
center of these triangles
form a straight line with
the shared ions.
For a three-dimensional
polyhedron, the sequence of
increasing repulsive energy
would be shared faces for
something like cubes,
shared edges--
that would be lower energy but
not the best you could do.
Shared corners would be the
best possible arrangement.
As you make each of those
transitions, you take the
central ion and keep the
separation between the
neighboring ion of like charge
as low as possible.
The interaction energy would
be as low as possible.
All right, so let
me stop there.
I think we're probably about
halfway through.
We can then determine ranges
of radius ratio for various
stoichiometries.
And all this is just a fantasy
unless we can say, do ions
have sizes that are the same
from compound to compound?
And, if so, how do we
determine them?
I hope that intriguing pair of
questions will keep you here,
dry and warm, rather than
heading off early.
OK, so let's take our usual
10-minute break and resume to
wrap this up.